-Lin-Manuel, I'm so happy
you're here. Lin-Manuel Miranda.
Your new documentary, "We Are
Freestyle Love Supreme..."
-'Preme, 'preme, 'preme.
-...is coming out --
That's right --
July 17th on Hulu.
I remember going backstage
to say hi to you guys
before the show.
Normally, I would go after.
But you were like,
"Maybe come before,
'cause there's a little special
something." And I go, "Alright."
And I went
and just hid in the corners,
like, under these pipes
in the theater.
And you guys did
this, like, kind of workout
where you'd pick words out of
a bag, and I was like, "Wow."
And already, I was like,
"Oh, no, this is unbelievable.
This is --"
Like, that was amazing to watch.
And it was just like,
you're like, "No, we're just
warming up and getting ready
for the show."
So I thought it'd be kind of fun
to do kind of
a freestyle right now.
But since we're both
stuck at home,
I want to switch things up
and challenge you to a new game.
This is "Random Object
Freestyle."
-♪ Random, object,
freestyle, object ♪
♪ Random object freestyle ♪
-Alright, here's how it works.
I will hold up a random object,
and then you have to start
freestyling about that object.
Every few seconds I'll show you
another random object.
You'll have to switch it up
and start freestyling
about that one.
Make sense?
-Yes.
-Alright, let's try it.
Start the beat.
♪♪
-♪ Okay, listen, I will ♪
♪ Give you an answer
no matter what the ask ♪
♪ It may be kind of mumbled
'cause I'm stuck behind a mask ♪
♪ Uh, yeah,
"Masque of the Red Death" ♪
♪ Edgar Allan Poe,
take my next breath ♪
♪ I'm hearing stereo,
no, "steerio" ♪
♪ Eatin' my Honey Nut Cheerios ♪
♪ I drop conquests,
what's the scenario? ♪
♪ I'm into Rosario on stereo ♪
♪ Got the Switch
'cause I'm scary-oh ♪
♪ Oh, I got the Switch,
I'm playing Animal Crossing ♪
♪ And I sold all my [bleep]
turnips, so how am I flossing? ♪
♪ Yes, online with my friends ♪
♪ Yup, got the Big Gulp,
sip it all up ♪
♪ Wish I had the syrup
and I was in heaven ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm drinkin' lots
of churros at my my 7-Eleven ♪
♪ And, aw, yes, I got that
calendar, vacation forever ♪
♪ Because this thing
is lasting forever ♪
♪ It's no endemic,
I tried to go to the Bahamas ♪
♪ But I ended up
in this [bleep] pandemic ♪
♪ The long and hard way ♪
♪ And yes, there's no shows on
on Broadway ♪
♪ But that's okay,
I will flush the dry turd ♪
♪ And keep going 'cause my show
is on July 3rd ♪
♪ Oh, you're going down
to download hot porn ♪
♪ While you're eating popcorn,
and yes, put the butter on it ♪
♪ Put Goya adobo
if you're Puerto Rican ♪
♪ You can eat it with me
every weekend ♪
♪ Please believe it, oh, no, not
"The Room Where It Happened" ♪
♪ John Bolton, aw, man ♪
♪ I can't believe
I have to respond to this ♪
♪ And beyond this, you should
have written that [bleep] ♪
♪ And testified
before Congress ♪
♪ "Hamilton" poster,
this is not the Cosa Nostra ♪
♪ This is just me spittin' out
my nostrils, boastin' fo' ya ♪
♪ I told you we're all gonna
get to see it, won't ya? ♪
♪ In the house
that the mouse built ♪
♪ And I just
get on my damn stilts ♪
♪ Like that Mickey Mouse
Clubhouse ♪
♪ The Goofy dance
with my underpants ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, and the house will ♪
♪ Don't open Disneyland yet,
but that's alright ♪
♪ 'Cause I understand that
this is just your damn pet ♪
♪ Having fun
with Jimmy Fallons ♪
♪ Bringing balance
with my freestylin' talents ♪
-Whoa!
[ Laughs ]
Whoo!
I don't know why I'm excited!
I am just relieved!
Wow!
How did you do that?
Oh! Gosh!
You had no idea
about any of that stuff.
-Yeah.
-That's just insanity.
-I hope you didn't pay
for that book, Jimmy.
-You're the best, dude.
I love you so much.
I can't even tell you.
I'm so happy.
I'm so excited.
July 3rd, Disney Plus,
"Hamilton."
July 17th, "We Are
Freestyle Love Supreme,"
on Hulu.
-'Preme, 'preme, 'preme, 'preme.
Lin-Manuel Miranda,
you're the best.
Best to the fam, dude.
Stay safe.
-Thanks. Same to yours, Jimmy.
Thanks for having me.
-Love you, bud.